[Music]
[Applause]
kevin frazier's joining with uh joining
us with uh nichelle turner whoa
how about this bonus coverage here
hi guys how much sleep have we had
none no no
what about dan i'm like the bonus jonas
today
michelle i would have taken just you
instead of k frey
that makes me feel better i've said i i
have text kevin a few times about how
great you are on entertainment tonight
yes well i am a long time fan of yours
and the show dan so i've been listening
and watching you guys for the longest so
i'm actually honored to be on with you
thank you thank you it's great to have
you guys on and thank you i know you
guys are busy today all right
where do you want to start here oh boy i
don't know let's let's start with this
dan here's here's here's where we should
start
that
throughout his run
will has been emotional about what's
going on and he and michelle talked
after the sag awards and will broke down
in tears talking about that he needed to
protect
women especially the women around him
right the black women around him is what
he said specifically he feels a charge
now that his life is taking a different
direction and he told me that he feels
like he needs to stand in the gap and
stand in protection of these women and
he was really emotional and actually
felt took pride in the fact that he felt
like he had been doing that through this
making of this movie king richard and
then on the um
awards season stage that he has been
really standing in protection of these
women now dan we all know
there was more stuff going on than just
that joke because you just tell that
joke any other you don't get that
response
something else was there there was 20
there was 2016 where chris really went
in on jada for boycotting the oscars
and then they've been the butt of the
jokes for months and months and months
so i don't know i'm not trying to make
excuses for what he did because we also
should say unapologetically it was wrong
to walk on that stage not say a word to
that man and slap him in his face
that was wild it's the wildest thing
that i have ever seen what happens
backstage are you guys backstage
no no we're not backstage and they don't
go backstage they're no no will went
right back to a seat
so tyler perry and denzel washington
came over and they began to talk to him
this happened in the commercial place
and will is visibly upset he's crying
and and then bradley cooper comes over
and hugs him and talks to him and gives
him words of encouragement his publicist
meredith o'sullivan as the break is
ending comes out to check on him she
kneels down next to him tiffany haddish
is talking to jada and whispering in her
ear everyone is trying to pull it back
together but nobody's checking on chris
that's my question
[Laughter]
where does chris go well we were asking
that tonight kevin and i went to we were
like where is chris did anybody see him
backstage did anybody nobody saw chris
chris just vamped he
left and so nobody's seen him since no
we don't know where we haven't heard
from him no we don't know anything about
what's going on with him but
but will after he was emotional after
winning somehow managed to put it all
back together and he went out he went to
the can we show can we show the video to
them oh can you guys see yeah let's see
if we can roll what happened with will
after the show
vanity fair party and he was he was in
the mix he was wrapped up so he's
dancing with his academy award yes to
his own music
yes getting jiggy with him yeah that
that he definitely was dan can i just
say and like i'm trying to make sense
about my soul is stretched from one side
of this room to the other i'm actually
very sad about the whole thing
i'm just really sad about all of it
because i thought the joke was in poor
taste but it was a joke and we know
chris rock does that acerbic comedy i
thought that will's reaction was
wild i thought that the fact that it
created this domino effect and it robbed
amazing moments from everybody else in
that room we were not talking about some
of the history-making moments and the
fact that it was a great show like it
was a really good show we haven't seen a
great oscars and many many many moons
long time um and so i think just the
fact that nobody is getting their shine
except for you know will chin checking
chris it's what it's sad to me
how what happens the rest of the week
with this oh boy
well first we've got to hear from chris
christie gotta hear from chris
that's the most important thing and his
reaction because you have to also
understand this chris is getting ready
to go on tour with kevin hart yeah now
that's material is this new material
and will that material
really
really go after the smith well i thought
that was gonna happen though you could
see chris when he went oh i
and i then i thought you're going to
slap me but you didn't slap somebody
else in your own house your life right
you know with your wife well you don't
slap obviously i guess august
is what you're saying yeah that's what
people are saying like you you know you
check chin checked him for a joke but
why you know listen i do think that this
creates material um chris did a a comedy
bit called never scared remember so
how about
red red table talks that chris shows up
with jada please let that happen that's
the other thing we talked about because
if he went to the red table the
conversation between he and will would
be epic jada will get her part in but i
want to hear what he has to say to will
and man the man because you don't have a
man moment because chris has come back
as well this is also from bed stuy so
will's from philly chris is from bed
stuy
both of those fellas like
know what
both of them come from and situations
where are your guys where are your boys
where was security last night that's
what i want to know
because i think dan everybody in the
place was confused they thought it was a
bit it's will smith he laughs it off
this is this is will just having fun
he's going to go up and he's going to
shake up chris and ha-ha-ha funny funny
and go back to his seat chris thought it
was a bit he called that man richard
when he watched it
richard
and then you heard the hit and then i
went that that's no skit
that's no ski i it listen it was so loud
and pronounced i thought that it was a
skit because i thought he hit the point
no i thought they added sound into it
it was just that harsh i was like oh
that was a bit and then when he went
back to the seat and started yelling i
was like oh but that wasn't a bit they
cut this and and for the television
audience they cut the sound so quickly
that then everyone was kind of confused
and they're like is my remote did
somebody sit on a remote what the hell
only thing i could make out from the lip
reading was my
wife like that so that's the only thing
and then when we saw like thank goodness
for like australian and japanese
television who had the uncensored [ __ ]
and we saw it and lupita nyong'o's face
oh boy but peter nyong was just like
your your day is easy today you got
right you've got a lot to talk about in
a paycheck today that's for sure hey
thanks for joining us can we talk about
the nba playoffs next time next time we
can next time we'll break it down we'll
break down you know what uh what's going
on with the lakers and james our friend
shaquille o'neal won an oscar and steph
curry they won oscars last night so
there you go but nobody's out there
overshadowed by nobody nobody's talking
about it today absolutely nobody's
talking about it uh we'll be watching i
know tonight i will when entertainment
tonight comes on it's 7 30 eastern
[Music]
thank you guys great to talk to you
thank you man appreciate it thank you
guys for having us nichelle turner and
her sidekick kevin frazier there nobody
covers the story like we do
man
you can tell they've been up all night
they got some stuff to do today